What will happen?
The Joe Rogan experience,
the biggest controversy in America in terms of transgender people?
Probably the biggest or one of the biggest is competing in sports with
biological women.
That's the biggest one.
Yes.
If you're asking me for answers on that,
haven't already got them.
I know.
Yeah.
I've got one good one for um,
for washrooms as you call them.
Lemon restaurant,
which is on the urinals as you call him.
He called me,
Ryan was just check them all out and everyone just,
it's all cubicles and we already do that in restaurants.
We already share stuff,
Eh,
the,
the toilets in,
right.
We did it in the airplanes we have now.
By the way,
if you just remove urinals at,
in theaters and places that won't be carrying often than women are queuing
forever and the men are not curing this way.
Everyone shares,
everyone behaves around responsibility.
I've heard of it working in a school as well.
There's less bullying in,
in the lose.
So it's that,
it just chuck a regression of technology.
I take it says get the euro,
check it out the window.
Everyone has a cubicle.
Just go to the loo and then use the mirrors and,
and,
and then go away.
It's just everything being for both genders.
Yeah.
You just make it all,
even then we get outside a lot of problems.
Some people will have pushed back on that and have other reasons why they didn't
like it.
But women don't want to be in a washroom with men though where they already are
going into.
If they're sharing in the losing the airplane,
if they're sharing it in there.
Yeah.
But it'll,
airplane is one,
you know,
it's only a strong person to go in there.
I think their,
their concern is there's,
you know,
some men are fucking creeps and some women just want to have a place where they
could just be themselves and their makeup and go to the bathroom and wash and
talk amongst other,
I understand that it's just,
I've,
you know,
um,
if you think about anything that's going to change anything,
that's usually something that won't,
wherever.
The only reason to do this is to accommodate people who are transgender in a way
that it seems like it doesn't,
it doesn't put them in a position where they,
they can be judged because everyone's doing it.
It makes,
well if he stops bullying for in,
you know,
in schools then it's,
it's,
it's a number of things in there that,
that,
that it can make easier.
It just makes a whole,
whole area of things a lot easier.
Do you think it stopped bullying though?
I didn't know what it has gone.
I mean,
I'm just giving you the figures of what kind of asset,
whether it just said that they tried it in the school and the bullying went
down.
She has this girls and his boys together and it's like boys were bullying the
boys or girls will believe the girls,
but if you,
yeah,
so it's trust them all together.
They don't,
it seems so now I just punish the creeps,
which is really what you,
I mean,
if someone's being a creep in the bathroom,
the problem is the creep.
It's not the bathroom.
Right?
Yeah.
It's,
um,
anyway,
so this is a,
you know,
I haven't scientifically proved this with chemicals and a slide rule of
whatever,
but it's an idea that gets to us to a better place and surely we're all
somewhere on the spectrum of something.
So the idea that,
um,
that anyone who is expressing themselves in a different way,
that that is a problem.
If you say,
if you take it by just stripe,
if we all went back to how we used to think that there was just men and women
and everyone had straight sex,
uh,
even s that sex,
that one,
we'll talk about that people,
you know,
Victorian age in your Quiver Victoria now,
no one would talk about that.
That was all horrible day.
Sex was a procreation was there,
the whole idea of everything.
So if you,
I'm trying to get out to a practical place where people just go to the loo and
behave like adults,
even the kids who have to behave more like adults,
which is interesting.
That makes,
that makes sense.
I see what you're saying.
Yeah.
Me.
That is the concern,
right?
Was it,
we have a system in place and someone tries to change the system,
then people get upset that the trends are,
and that always happens.
Yeah.
I mean,
uh,
but also women do queue forever and men don't queue at all.
Cute,
much less.
But this Mexico,
it's Mexico queuing even evens that out.
So everyone just behaves like an echo,
you know,
it's just a toilet.
The Romans used to have it with open plan toilets.
I've seen that.
We have made it into a problem.
We have made this a whole psychological problem.
Where's the ramen?
Just sit down there and I have a pool and have a chat.
And once they did make it a problem and categorize people by gender,
then it became this thing.
And now you don't want to change that.
Well,
yeah,
I don't think the,
that they might've had many male and female toilets in the Roman times,
but just the fact that they were more open about the idea.
There's bodily functions and it's normal.
And we've,
you know,
back in the,
uh,
before we came in and we were just going out into the woods and the forest and
having a pool and it was just having a food and now we feel it's a big problem
having a period.
We didn't like the fact we haven't,
but we don't want to admit that we have the per,
does the queen ever have a poop?
Maybe never has the attitude be besides the marathon thing?
Has the attitude culturally shifted in the UK is the same way it shifted in
America where people are more,
I think the more,
more and more people are out and a positive.
I mean you've basically got two from every grip.
This is ethnic groups is from women.
That's just from any one that it feels slightly out of the loop.
If you can have a pause,
any positive role models that go out there that do other things,
you know,
just something that's nothing to do with sexuality.
You're very good at cooking.
You're on television for this tends to be television helps.
Um,
you got sports style,
you're this,
you're that.
They want to those things people say,
well there's a positive role model and they are of a different color or over
different sexuality or their,
you know,
and that just helps everyone adjust their mindset.
And the younger people come through and they,
oh,
that's all they know.
I know about this person offered me like,
you know,
um,
in baseball you see the Bait,
that famous documentary basketball,
the um,
Ken Burns.
Yeah.
The Ken Burns one and that black people after the civil war,
black people were playing baseball.
And there was some guy who was very powerful.
He said there'll be no black people in major leagues at all.
And it was blocked from about 1890,
something this all the way through to 1950s.
So it was actually happening and then it went backwards.
Yeah.
So there was a positive role mum then.
Well,
they've been,
well,
why over that happen.
Things can go backwards and things go forward.
And I just think if we're trying to get to a world where everyone's living that
live,
yeah,
that's really what we need,
right?
Yeah.
Just live and let live,
live.
And as long as you're not interfering with other people's lives,
you,
as long as you're not doing something that somehow or another fucks with someone
else.
Yeah.
Like who cares?
Why would anyone care?
Yeah.
I mean I think people care because they're unhappy with themselves.
I think that's the only time people care and let my,
my issue with this that I've come across is with athletes.
It's with transgender athletes competing against women,
particularly in my field and fighting.
All right.
Um,
there's been,
uh,
some,
there have been at least there was one very vocal case.
One very public case of a transgender athlete who was a male for 30 plus years,
transitioned over for a couple of years,
for two years,
and then started fighting.
Women didn't tell them that she used to be a man.
Right.
And it became a giant issue and people were outraged and anger.
The women who got beat up or angry cause they got destroyed.
Two of them did.
And then she started,
then she was public about it and then started fighting women that were willing
and new,
you've got to say things up front.
I mean,
I came out that long ago because I wanted to be up front about things.
So yeah,
I don't have the great answers.
There's,
you know,
for,
I don't have the answer for everything,
but yeah,
I can see that from,
one of the interesting things about it is that there are no real answers,
that it's one of those things where you just got to go home.
What do we do here?
And this is,
this is what I think one of the more unique things about being a person is that
we have this opportunity to look at this unusual circumstance and communicate
about it and try to figure it out.